now this is a story all about how my
life got flipped turned upside down
this really was the tv reunion that we
needed in 2020 we've been waiting so
long for this
hey y'all looking like you about to tell
my business
[Laughter]
but here's the thing we're going to keep
it going with my guest co-host tatiana
ali
how are people reacting to the fresh
print reunion oh
people are reacting with so much love
and tears
and laughter but you know what y'all
this is going to be like the official
after party
[Music]
we have so many of the banks family
members right here
daphne karen and joseph joining us now
and so
thank you guys for being here i'll start
with daphne what has the
reaction been like for you like a big
hug
people are reacting like oh thank
goodness a
family is going to get together this
thanksgiving oh and
a complete emotional rollercoaster when
we did it
the good old days when we arrived on
that set
it was exhilarating good old days look
at this
without a doubt talking about james
avery
and the tribute to him it was a lot
that was the thing james he pushed me
so hard i know where i come from
it's like oh come on don't do it i know
i'm sorry
throwing me off what was it like for you
on the set
uh it was it was emotional i thought it
was a very beautiful
remembrance of him one of the things we
see in the special is that e.t
spent a lot of time on the set of the
fresh prince we were actually
at the final table read for the series
and we have a clip
that we want to show everybody we've
been very blessed and i don't know if
we'll ever have the same kind of
camaraderie and the kind of of love
this has been the best experience
in terms of a tv show in terms of
people and friends and happiness and
i've got to stop now
okay when you hear that voice and you
hear those words what does it mean to
you
[Music]
i miss him karen why are you gonna do it
to me
and watching the show and like watching
that clip i can't get over how much
he's here i feel him this is my daughter
you mess with her you mess with me i
will hurt you
okay i think that's absolutely right i
think he's here and when we all come
together we feel him
will also felt it was important to
include janet
in this reunion i played the role of
vivian banks
i guess they call me the og the original
amphibian
janet hubert played on viv for the first
three seasons of the fresh prince
before the role was recast with daphne
during the hbo max reunion
janet and will finally made peace ending
their decades-long feud
when i left the show i lost everything
but you know those words calling a black
woman difficult
in hollywood is the kiss of death it's a
guess of death
and i'm sorry that i have blasted you to
pieces
first of all thank you for
uh sharing that with me i felt like you
hated me
what did you learn from that
conversation that you saw between um
will and janet
me personally i learned a lot about
janet's story that i didn't know i also
just learned a lot about
forgiveness i thought that was a really
amazing
thing to to see it represented
what the show is about the show is about
a bunch of people loving each other
[Applause]
i think one thing that really surprised
me was i felt like this
huge weight came off of me that i didn't
even know
this is what we all really needed
i had never met her so that was the
first time i met her
i knew she belonged there she started
this so
to clear that whole air for the internet
at large guys
it's fine like whichever aunt vivian you
want or like both of us
it doesn't really matter love the show
hey look like will said i can't wait for
y'all to do this again
in 10 years for the 40th anniversary
actually we should do it again in five
don't wait that long thanks everybody
for joining us thank you